well as you already know if you've been
paying any attention at all the southern
poverty law center is an
entirely fraudulent enterprise the
organization has nothing to do with the
south
or with poverty it's a left-wing
political group that uses hate crime
designations to target its ideological
enemies
and to crush people in 2012 the splc
inspired a shooting attack on the family
research council by labeling
labeling the innocuous christian
organization a hate group
just last month the splc paid 3.3
million dollars for falsely calling the
quilliam foundation quote
anti-muslim extremists we could go on
southern poverty law center
lies they are utterly reckless and
they're totally dishonest
with that in mind it was shocking to
discover as jaded as we are and this
show has discovered it exclusively
that the fbi has a long history of
collaborating with the southern poverty
law center
in 2009 for example the fbi called the
splc
quote a well-known established
incredible organization that
monitors domestic terrorism in the u.s
the splc repeatedly has been allowed to
brief
fbi personnel on alleged terror threats
to this country
disturbingly though this relationship is
ongoing if you can believe it
despite multiple requests from this
program the fbi has refused to describe
the extent of its collaboration with the
splc we've asked repeatedly or even to
explain why it continues to work with a
group like that
instead we've received meaningless and
mindless boilerplate statements like
this one quote
for many years the fbi has engaged with
various organizations both formally and
informally
such outreach is critical critical
component of the fbi's mission
and we welcome information from these
organizations on any possible violation
of civil rights hate crimes or other
potential crimes or threats
we do however evaluate our relationships
with these groups as necessary to ensure
the appropriateness of any interaction
again
mindless pap that does not answer the
question we can report tonight that
congressman matt gates of florida
has sent a letter to fbi leadership
asking them to explain
their relationship with the splc which
is obviously very troubling to put them
mildly
then tonight the doj gave us another
statement this one said quote
the attorney general has directed the
fbi to reevaluate their relationships
with groups
like this the splc to ensure the fbi
does not partner with any group
that discriminates end quote as the splc
certainly does masjid nawaz is the
founder of quilliam he just received
that settlement we mentioned from the
splc after they libeled him
as an extremist he's also the author of
a tremendous book called radical my
journey out of islamist extremism
muchi nawaz joins us tonight thanks very
much for coming on
so it was it was partly from watching
what they did to you
that had us asking the question well you
know to what extent are they involved
with the federal government and we we
discovered this but
tell our viewers who maybe haven't
followed this as close to your
experience with the splc
well it's curious and fascinating at the
same time
because i have been born and raised a
muslim i
spent the my teenage years in fact with
an islamist organization
seeking to enforce sharia law
in muslim majority societies because i
got radicalized
i ended up as a political prisoner in
egypt for my beliefs
and it was in jail that i reformed my
views and came out
vowing to challenge islamist extremism
and founded quilliam in 2008
and have been doing so now for 10 years
and the southern
poverty law center decided to compile a
list of what they deemed
as anti-muslim extremists and the
oddity the sheer oddity of placing
a muslim on a list of anti-muslim
extremists is what led me to then say
i need justice in this case because my
entire life tucker has been defined
by my struggle and i got it wrong
initially i've been open about that i
wrote about it in my book
my struggle to find a place for muslims
in the west
that is at home with the west um and and
so to undermine my entire life's work by
placing me on a list of anti-muslim
extremists i found
a step too far and that's why um i went
to lawyers and got advice and uh it's
why we took the action we did
and i can say someone who's interviewed
scores of people like you i think you
were one of the most restrained and
thoughtful and reasonable people on this
topic i've ever interviewed so to call
you an extremist is very odd
and dishonest so what effect did it have
on you once a group like this
defines you as an extremist i mean
that's got to hurt
your foundation i would think well first
of all i've got to say it places a
target
on the heads look it's it's no secret
it's already hard enough
for muslim reformers liberal muslim
reformers to speak out against extremism
within our communities
people that do so are often targeted and
often killed
there was a similar list that was
published in bangladesh against
so-called muslim heretics
and many of them were knocked off
assassinated by jihadists because they
were deemed
to be blasphemous or heretical uh ayan
herciale who has since sought refuge in
the united states of america
her her close friend the film director
teo van gogh was murdered on the streets
of hampton amsterdam
and then a list was stabbed into his
body and it named aeon as being next
that's what we're up against here and so
the first thing it did is it placed me
in grave danger it placed ayaan herciali
in grave danger because she was
also named on this list but it also had
material consequences
um when they did what they did the
reason they produced these lists is to
convince media
and to convince philanthropists and
foundations not to
not to give grants to these sorts of
people or these organizations
and it did have those kind of material
consequences for us as well
and it's why we couldn't just lie back
and and uh and take this
at face value as it was we had to take
action
and i'm glad that you did and the fact
that our fbi is collaborating with the
group
this discredited and reckless is really
scary
um thank you very much for your account
i appreciate that and congratulations on
winning you deserve it thank you
very much thank you appreciate it